well you know it's it's good to keep
busy before I get into this one quick
announcement my patrons have been aware
of this for a while but I now have a
pedo box
so I have absolutely no idea and it's
with some more than a little bit of
nervousness that I am going to now make
that public so if you wish to send to me
something whether it's just a letter or
whatever else I kind of nervous to think
about what people might want to try and
send me but you can send it to the PIO
box and that address is going to be down
in the description along with all the
other stuff ok topic at hand so there's
been some news over at Fox which I think
caught a lot of people off-guard because
you know Fox is in the process of being
acquired by Disney and while it's still
possible for that deal to fall through
or to change in some way I'm not really
gonna be dealing with that well I'm
instead gonna be dealing with his Fox's
announced continued plans for films
specifically in regards to the x-men
franchise now again I think this caught
some folks off-guard and they were they
were rather surprised by it I'm not
overly like I was a little when I saw
the headline but then I read it and like
I don't know that makes perfect sense so
what it is that there that has actually
been confirmed is that we are currently
still getting to x-men movies this year
that's Deadpool 2 and then x-men Dark
Phoenix they are sticking to the plan to
release three x-men related movies next
year another three in 2020 we know at
least one of those is going to be new
mutants that's next year we found out a
little bit more about the reshoots for
that apparently they're integrating
another character no idea who it is if I
were to guess I don't have a specific
guess but it's probably somebody that
they hope they can do spin-off material
with that would be my own supposition
beyond that they're now actively working
on a Silver Surfer movie and they had
announced not all that long ago that
Brian Michael Bendis is working on a
kitty pryde solo film Plus in addition
to the
there's still the dr. doom movie that no
Hollies working on so they seem pretty
busy for a company that's in the process
of being bought but that's not really
that surprising see the thing is
whenever a company gets acquisition door
you know bought out whatever the thing
is is that business has to continue as
usual until the deal is actually done
and the transition takes place because
you can't just have the Fox people
sitting on their butts twiddling their
thumbs waiting for the merger to have it
waiting for the the acquisition to take
full effect and doing nothing in the
meantime because then that then the
entity that is twenty-first second
Century Fox actually loses value because
if you don't keep these people busy
they're gonna find work elsewhere and
then Disney is no longer acquiring you
know the resources of Fox thoroughly
acquiring the IP that's not as valuable
that changes the deal so they needed to
keep busy and so none of this is overly
surprising um my big question and this
is something that we don't know at this
point my big question is whether or not
the new films that they're working on
are the things that they were always
going to do or if they're now adjusting
their plans with the I on the fact that
Disney is going to take over these
properties because I think we can pretty
much take it as a given that once Disney
has his hands on the x-men
it is not gonna continue the continuity
of Fox's x-men universe that's gonna get
closed off the asterisk goes over
Deadpool but Deadpool's fourth-wall
breaking he can be his own thing and it
makes total sense and they're not gonna
ditch him he's too valuable but they're
it's not worth their hassle to try and
integrate that continuity so what I'm
curious about because like I said the
2019 x-men movies the one we know for
Shores New Mutants that one actually has
a release date the other ones most
likely to be ready by 2019 are x-force
and that ties into Deadpool and gambit
now gambit is a character who
technically was introduced
in x-men origins Wolverine but they're
not doing that version of gambit it's a
standalone film that's the plan for it
that's always been the plan so what I
will be really curious about is whether
or not x-force and gambit more
specifically are gonna have any ties
back to the main Fox x-men continuity my
suspicion is probably not with exports
there's no need to because it's leaping
off of Deadpool it doesn't have to tie
back to that other stuff and in regards
to gambit if they have him you know have
not you know established all of this
means there's this but if they don't
have anybody from the other films
appearing cameo a if they don't make
over references to events that happened
in that continuity then yeah they've
made again but film but it's one that
could be slotted into the MCU it's one
that as long as they don't make over
connections could be adopted I don't
mean like Disney will cancel the project
once that once the full transition
happens because look this merger and
full transition is gonna take a long
time so there's a good chance that even
if Disney would prefer this movie not
happened that things like gambit exports
are still gonna happen they're gonna be
too far along by the time busy act and
Disney actually has direct say over what
goes on but even if they want to kill it
it's a waste of resources so the this is
gonna happen no matter what but I do
wonder if they're adjusting their plans
and I doubt they're working directly
with Disney I doubt there's any hey is
this is this what you want guys but I
wouldn't be shocked if they're looking
at these projects and making little
adjustments to tone down and minimize
direct connections to their existing
continuity so that they can go hey you
know we've got this character who's not
really tied in if you want to keep this
franchise going you know keep these
these producers this director this actor
employed on contract we've got ready to
go if you want them I would not be
shocked if that's kind of the way
they're approaching this especially when
it comes to the Silver Surfer because
honestly though that one was the one
that surprised me continuing to work on
x-men not a huge shock x-men is the
thing that Fox seems to have a better
handle on than most of the things they
still make missteps and I expect Dark
Phoenix to be a big one but they're
doing well enough with that franchise so
preserve that's a whole other ball of
wax and that one's weird to me that
they're that they're moving forward
working on a Silver Surfer movie for a
couple of reasons first is there's the
automatic stigma that they already had
him appear in one of their earlier
fantastic four movies and that did what
this is successful enough for a sequel
but beyond that the silver circle surfer
by his nature and not just him
specifically to look potentially just
him but even beyond that if you're doing
the Silver Surfer story if you're doing
that level of cosmic that's expensive
that's a lot of money to realize that
well at all
I you know the guardians of the galaxy
movies are not cheap even over at DC
they spend a ton of money on Green
Lantern it looked like crap but they
spend a lot of money on it cuz that kind
of stuff is really that kind of cosmic
stuff is really expensive to realize and
something like Silver Surfer is gonna be
really CGI heavy because otherwise it
just looks like a guy who'd in its
silver body pain that's not gonna fly so
I I have to wonder if that is being done
you know as again as something that will
carry over I get I doubt being planned
in conjunction with Disney but the thing
is to remember that when it comes to
20th Century Fox these people are
probably and I mean from the top down
the executives to the actual on-site
producers assistants everybody everybody
who works for 20th Century Fox they've
got to be a bit worried about their jobs
and whether or not they're still going
to be around once the acquisition
happens and it's kind of to their
benefit to have as many things that they
have their fingers in that are
transferable not only IP but existing
franchises over to Disney
I think Silver Surfer could potentially
be a very appealing property for Disney
whether or not the idea Fox making the
that movie on their own before Disney
gets his hands on it makes Disney
nervous
I don't know but Silver Surfer has a lot
of potential especially considering that
James Gunn has said he's planning to
close out his take on the guardians of
the galaxy with volume 3 of that film
and the question then becomes well how
where do we keep going with cosmic side
of Marvel after that you know some of
those actors could you know reuptake on
tracks but they're only contracted
through for the three of them and you
know there were Avengers appearances but
James gotta said he's got to be done
with that story he's setting up Adam
warlock so unless he dies somewhere
along the line he's an easy go-to but
other than that the Silver Surfer would
be a really good recognizable hook in to
keep the cosmic side of the MCU going in
the absence of of an ongoing Guardians
franchise so the whole thing I I've
actually just found quite fascinating
and I don't as so often happens with
these sorts of news I read the original
one original or just just news based
write-ups I don't read the opinion
pieces what people are saying feeling
suspecting whatever about these because
I in this case especially I look at this
and go oh you know what maybe we'll get
some interesting things out of this
because I mean at this point really what
does what does Fox have to lose I mean
they're getting bought whether even if
they deal with Disney falls through
Rupert Murdoch wants to sell this off
it's getting sold no matter what so I
mean there might as well keep busy they
might as well keep cranking stuff out
maybe they'll even get more daring who
knows and they were already going some
interesting directions with these so
those are sort of my general thoughts on
the news for the more recent stuff
that's come out about what Fox is doing
working on x-men and also Silver Surfer
so first of all things man that is that
is weird to think about so I mean what
are other folks thoughts on this do you
think this is good this is
bad do you think they're gonna create
some interesting stuff do you think it's
gonna be bland do you think they're
actually just burning the house down
before they all bail whatever your
thoughts are drop something out in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
that stuff to do we'd like support me on
patreon a buy t-shirt and Twitter and
podcasts and like subscribe yeah all
that stuff links for everything is down
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]